Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to subnautica. We are in my base
As it turns out
I'm a bit of an idiot and you guys may be surprised by this
But sometimes I don't pay attention to things that are on menus like in the Builder icon if I tab over
There's a whole bunch of other things there
You know that kind of show me what is there so I could have done that at any moment and I didn't do that anyway
I've now got lockers. I've got a fabricator. I've got solar panels which I could have built at any moment
I got a beacon that helps me locate this spot. I've done a lot of farming just to get it out of the way
I've got a lot of farming done and I've got lots of materials also
I found this spinner fish which I didn't know about before but I found this spinner fish and it was so cute
And I'm gonna cook it and I'm gonna eat it just so you all know what the deal is about that
I also got lockers here again, which means that I'm gonna put names on them. I've already put some names on these
I'm gonna read them out and the comments that they were associated with thank you everybody so much for commenting and watching the last episode
Prec (Preesh) you prec you bigley prec you hard there goes starfish. Sorry. Oh man, that's it. Doesn't look too good
Anyway, I need to get food in me. Uh, nom nom nom, nom
Delicious. Alright, so thank you Jenna bina who said
Oh my god, that would be so funny
If you have to go searching for the blueprints for the modification station
and it takes you like 30 episodes like it did last time no, I
Disagree, I hope I get it a lot sooner than that and let's just hope that everything goes just real smooth here
All right
Next up is Ian West who just said give me the suck and I can really relate and appreciate to especially in this game
Which is so much about suck. The next is sky fawn who said mark next video interact with the glow whales I I
Don't know what that means. So I'm gonna try it out and then Sukho scribble who said mark
whales whales mark
Which I can only imagine is what they said. But before I do that I have wait, maybe not on me
I have the materials to get the scanner room because I don't know this area at all. I don't know anything that's going on. So
The scanner room is actually going to be a useful tool for me to understand what's happening around me and where I am
So this is the base that I built in the last one. I also put some windows on it for nice aesthetics
but if I can have the scanner room and I can power it properly then I'm gonna assume that I
Can get what I need and yeah, this should be fine
If it works the same way that it did before and I don't need to get like upgrade modules for it initially it should scan
Everything help me fool. Help me find items that I need. That's not right. That don't look right. That looks okay
Oh that looks fun. Camera two camera one. I do not need those on my beacons
So let's just not do that because I don't intend to lose them
But that does mean that I can use those to kind of explore around which is kind of cool. Ah, there we go
Oh hell yeah
Breakable gold breakable lead fragment fragments ate a box. Ooh
heat area, whoa
Let's go data box cuz that's kind of what I'm really? Whoo
It's at a date a box. Where's that way?
Is that the one that I already got in the twisty bridges that might be already the one that I got?
I don't know how far away it is, but I'm pretty sure that might be the one that I got
Yeah upgrades and what oh I can make upgrades. Oh
Shit streams data from scanner rooms to the HUD. Oh
shit
Oh
Shit do I have any magnetite? I don't even remember getting any magnetite. Do I have any magnetite Oh
Frick yes, I do. Do I have any copper though? I spent all but no I didn't. Okay. Alright scanner room upgrade. Damn
Okay pop that bad boy in
All right, whoa
That got bigger. I think did it get bigger I have no idea. Is that what I was supposed to do?
Anyway, I think it was speed. Why not? Right? Why not? Okay
Plop that bad boy in there
Okay. Now it's faster for some reason. I don't know. Maybe that's not that's not what I did
I'm assuming this is where we are my two bases. Oh that seems down in the twisty bridges area, but
Again, I'm not a hundred percent. Sure. Let's so let's close that out and let's change it to fragments. Okay, that's a different location
That's much closer. There's a fragment over there apparently
Let me do the HUD to update. No, I don't have enough magnetite
I think that must have been my only
Magnetite I would have done that first if I knew they both needed magnetite what god damn it, okay
Well shit, um fuck. Let me dump some of this table coral. I don't think I need that it needs a computer chip to
Gold and copper wire. Okay. I need to get more copper and I need to go get more or magnetite. Ooh
There's lots of fragments. Whoo. There's something down there. Hey, let me see what that is
That's nearby. I think it's just outside this door here. Was it if that's those two, was it down here? No. Oh
Hey red guy. Hey, hey, red, red, red, red, dive dive. Oh
Hey
Hi, where am I? Oh
Whoa
What is that? Oh, it's a penis. Oh, it's a penis. All right
Very clearly a penis
Very clearly one hundred percent of it. I know bean is when I see it. Oh, yes Oh, what is that?
What is this? I bet there's some Leviathan underneath buried underneath her and it died belly-up. Just dick out belly-up
Which is such a way to go. Oh my god
Okay. All right fun
This place seems fun
All right, you know what I don't want to get trapped down here so I'm just gonna get out of here
I'm gonna get out here and I'm just gonna remember this place as the penis cave for now
We're how do I get out of here? Is it this way?
I need I need no, I need copper not any of these but okay. That's that's a new one. That is new
Okay, great. I have no idea where I am in relation to my beacon. There is my beacon, okay
So where are those artifacts if I had the magnets I'd I'd be able to stream it straight to my HUD, but you know
Oh, well can't do that. I need to drop some stuff anyway, and then the fish
Okay, so wait, where was okay. So, let me check again. I do need to go get whoa
Okay, there's a ton down there wherever that is
there's just a ton of
Fragments, I don't know what happens if you get all the Prometheus fragments or whatever. They were called Pathfinder
Fragments the plumper dink fragments. There's something fragments. I don't remember what they are
but if I get those
but I need to get magnetite any way to get that on my HUD because it's just gonna be hard to navigate and I know
Where the magnetite was who's over to the other side where the the sea emperor was first?
I'm gonna go back to the whales because of what uh,
I'd lose sky fawn said go back to the whales and interact with them or more specifically poke him in the eye
I think I don't know why I would poke them in the eye, but I'm gonna go poke him in the eye
So yeah, let's do that. That seems like a good idea
Well, that's new just a floating that oh, there we go now it's back Oh,
Storms rolling in man these storms roll in quick. Oh
My god, that's
Dad, that was a bit too close. Okay. Thank you for that. Let me poke you in the eye. How about that? Oh
Oh
Shit. Oh, oh, this is not a good idea
Hi
That's not the best idea I've ever had probably just pissed it off I don't know what war why I did that
But yeah, we were from your mouth your mouth. Not your mouth. Oh, okay. There are so many whales
There's so many whales only there's so many ones but there's so many whales okay
So that was a fun diversion that's terrifying at the same time
But I need to go get some magnetite I can just go until I see like a lily pad
It's real. Well, that's weird. That's not right. Hey wait, so I'm not right about this
So I mean Oh
some
Can I get some so I just gotta say something something's a little off here some table corals looking roll around for that
All right way, all right. There's a little bit bad
Things just below here. Here we go down here in the horribleness. Okay. I have not explored this area very much
So, I don't know if there's anything besides the sea Emperor here and I can't even spot where MP is
So that's fun
My body is physically telling me to run away and I'm trying to fight that instinct
Magnetite your Ruby you're not magnetite. I need magnetite. Oh, did I get it from over here? I may be mistaken
I may be very mistaken Oh Nelly
Nelly
Nelly were gone deep
Okay, I need oxygen oh shit there's a whale I didn't know whales were out here too
magnetite a lot of quartz quartz quartz
whoa, whoa
Is that a bass? Oh shit found a bass. Cool. That looks like a robust bass - okay
It is night also, which is very bad. Very very bad. I'm very far. I'm very far. I'm in the middle of nowhere
I'm very far away. Let's get in the bass cuz that's relatively safe. Maybe there'll be something in there
Maybe it may be the secrets of building a seamoth again wood given to me
I don't know maybe okay, let's let's we can get in here without
Ya, okay. There we go. Hello
Can I scan anything anything at all would be great. Oh hello
Colleague PDA. Okay Jeffries log
Looking for Jeffrey. I can't remember caring. Ooh, there's battery chargers. That'd be nice to have but it won't let me scan those barely. Ooh
It's a moon pool
For a seamoth I want that. Can I get that? I want to see moth I want that so badly. It's a scanner room. Oh
I want that so badly. Yeah. I saw some observation things above
I just don't know how to get to that like some observation stalks here. Oh is in the middle of that? Okay
Hang on hang on. Hang on. I got enough oxygen. It's in the middle of this what?
That doesn't make any sense. It doesn't go up
Why hey, whoa
Whoa, whoa
Whoa, whoa. Whoa. Whoa Nellie. You don't need to get to me that desperately. Yeah. All right. That was fun
Glad that happened. All right, so that's something but that isn't what the data says
Your calling was aware of my existence
You cannot pass this information to your masters what I have to send this to all Tara
It might save Jeffrey's life, but there are many humans that only want to me. My survival is paramount
I'm gonna delete the entries it won't be cleaned
But it won't expose us either animation of deleting entries from Jeffrey's PDA open transmission Vesper. I found Jeffrey's PDA
No new leads, but the techies might be able to extract something useful great. Send it up as soon as you can Roger, okay?
Hey mobile vehicle bay wait, can I make that it's in my thing. Can I make that?
Can I make that now? Wait, can I make that do I have a blueprint of it?
I don't like sitting out in the middle of the ocean, but frankly, I guess it's okay. No, no, I can't
Well, why not? I want it. I want it. I want it badly. I don't know
I don't know what to do with this but let's keep looking for magnetite and hope that we can get
Hope that we can get some and get the scanner room upgraded because that's gonna help maybe question. I don't know. Maybe not maybe not
I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I'm going I hate it. I hate it. I'm going I'm a big boy
I'm going oh, it keeps going. Oh god. I hate it. I hate it. I hate it so much
I hate I hate everything about it. I hate it. Oh
my
god, oh
My
god
Where am I Oh
What is that?
Well what I don't know what I'd what did I just get?
Lily pad resource, okay
Great. I don't know what oh
Oh, oh what?
Jelly, shroom. Oh
Okay, I can't get that okay, I gotta go I am out of oxygen there's no oxygen here I gotta go
I gotta go gotta go. I'm Way too deep I'm way too deep. She's gonna pretend like we didn't go down
They're just gonna pretend like absolutely nothing was anywhere ever
Okay, where am I orient myself? Okay. We're still in the lily pads area. Let's just keep going
I don't think there's gonna be anything down there or if there is something down there
It's gonna pretend like it doesn't exist guys. Frankly. I don't think I need it. There's got to be magnetite somewhere here
I keep getting distracted because I keep finding new things
It's too empty over here
If there isn't a Reaper here right now or anything, whatever the equivalent would be for this area
quartz still
No, no, no, no no no no, I
Just had to say something I
Just had to say something. I just had to say something. I just had to say something
I had to say something and I just had to open my big flappers
I just had to open my big flappers Oh if they didn't put in if they didn't put in a lava Reaper yet
It'd be here. I just had to open my big flappers. I don't know where the magnetite is. Oh
Where am I? It's so dark. It's so dark. It's so dark. It's so dark. This just goes down
Look at my radar. It just goes down. It just goes down. Oh god. I'm in a cave of some kind
Oh god, where am I? I can't see anything. Goodbye. Flashlight better. Oh my god. Oh my god little bitey bitches here
Oh shit will a bad timing. Does that magnetite?
Lithium, whoa a lot of bitey bitches. Why are there so many this goes down? Why does it just keep going down? Why?
Lithium, I don't know I got that. I gotta go back up. Okay, so that goes down forever. Okay. Well found that good didn't
Good to know Oh
What is that what the fuck what what the fuck
What I'm gonna die because I've hit something Oh, I'm going I'm going I'm going I'm not gonna make it
I'm gonna make it not gonna make it
I'm gonna make it
Comes to clean my salt Blanc
Wow, all right. Okay, I think this is a waste but I got some lithium which you know
That also is something that I probably need. I also found a pit into hell
So that's a thing that exists also and that's really cool that I know where that is now and that'll be burned into my brain
Forever so it's all really it's all it's all looking up for me
Now why is this like this? Why? Oh this goes this goes down to forever. Okay
Well, this is yes just goes down
Ended. Yeah, it just goes down
No, no, no, I don't need to explore anymore. You know, I I just realized I actually don't need to explore anything ever
So I'm not going to I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to
Do that ever again Oh
Diamond diamond. Okay, I got diamond Oh more diamond. Oh don't know what that's for
I always felt like that should be more valuable than it just is but it just it's not so I got diamond
You know what? I could have done I could have set my scanner to look for magnetite and
Then go in that general direction
And I would have gotten it
So I could have done that but now I've just got a bunch of diamonds. So who's the loser now?
It's me. Okay. I am definitely this time gonna go look for magnetite from the Skinner room
Because I've gone everywhere and I cannot find this magnetite
Whoa
That's a lot of fragments Wow
Holy shit, but screw all that we need magnetite. That's what we need. All right, look for magnetite, baby. Oh
Did the only one in the area I don't even know where that is, where's that in relation to here?
Please tell me you're gonna find more. All right, in the meantime. I need to go take care of something. Anyway, go get some fluids
Okay, let's grill us up some peepers and
How about some Wawa?
I like Wawa and I like peepers. So I want both. Okay, what do we bow just to
Wow, okay, there's something down this Chunnel looking thing. I don't know. What's north
I don't know what South I don't know. It's West. I don't know. It's East it's in like some cavern way deep
There are not a lot of pieces of magnetite around here
But I'm looking for like a path down this way
Okay, if this is the building and where's the twisty bridges from here is that this way? I don't know I do not know
Okay, if that's the ice, okay, this is the ice. Okay, if that's the ice and that's kind of like that way
Maybe it is just that way
So if I go that way the ice should be down that way it might be dead like straight ahead from it
I don't know. We're gonna find it. I shouldn't waste in my magnetite on the speed one
Let me just I'm gonna go up and I'ma look for the glade the the ice bed because that's really gonna tell the story
Yeah, it is so it should be
Due that way, right? Okay
You should be just this way and I just need to look for a long tunnel
Kind of thing and then somewhere in the back ass of it. It's where I got to go, right?
Yes where I gotta go might be in one of the tunnels that like this led through this looks like a tunnel
Look like a whiny ass tunnel that goes back and kind of convolute live
Tournament aback ass end of it. It's a magnetite. Maybe there's the harrowing quest for magnetite right now, maybe not
no, I
Don't know where I am, but it doesn't feel right. I think I took a wrong turn somewhere
Damn, oh, oh, oh shit. Oh fuck. No. No not like this not like this not like this
I'm too young and too pretty no I like this. Ah
Fuck I'm an idiot. Oh god, damn it. Oh
And there I go. Oh
I made it. Oh shit. All right. Well I made that
That was dumb, but I made it so hey not so dumb. Now. Am I? Oh warning emergency power. Only power stored. What?
Don't you see power only what's draining my power
What?
Where am I? I have no idea where I am. I am unsure
Okay, I don't know how I got here
But I am way far from home. Oh, hey, buddy, you look bigger than usual
um
Yeah, I don't know where I am. But I got out pretty far. So I'm probably gonna end up being stranded here
Whoa. Oh
Okay here we can construct the vessels. We require this will then we will secure our freedom what?
Our freedom
You not an enemy of our people that what I'm looking for magnetite. I'm I'm looking for magnet. Oh my god
I'm gonna drown I'm a drought. I'm gonna drown I'm going to drown I'm looking for magnetite. I found a precursor base thing
I'm a bobber that wasn't done so
Great, I guess we found the place where we're gonna build our ships. I
Guess I just want Magda said I just wanted so bad. It's just one is so badly
Oh god, okay. Yes. I know. I'm gonna die Oh God. I don't have enough. I see one magnet so bad hundred one
I just one magnetite please. Can I get magnetite? I just want magnetite. I just want that sweet tight magnetite
Oh, oh my hands cramping up from just pressing W so much just going forward is killing me. Oh
Where does this go Oh, where does this go? Oh, my god is so deep
What was that I
Hate it
It just goes down
It just goes down. It just keeps going down. Oh boy keeps going down. Okay, great
Oh right found some caves
Boyo did know magnetite down here searched far and wide for a big hole in the ground. Okay, I'm leaving
I'm very much leaving. Thank you. I'm very much leaving. I just want to leave I am good. Thank you
I apprec-- you so hard diamond for my trouble. Thank you. Oh, thank you. No
Thank you. Okay. Thank you. I am out of here. I tried so hard
And got so far but in the end it doesn't even matter
Or what?
Fucking where is that?
Where is that?
There's magnetite there. Where is that? Oh my god
Are you kidding me? Oh my
Goodness gracious
Oh, no, that's like in the Deepest of the Deep. Also. There's a whole other Deep Deep down Deep below and there's a scraggly
Dip Deeper that goes Deep down there. There are these two rogue magnetites that just don't exist. I don't know man
I tried really hard. I tried really hard to find these and then there's a whole bunch of them down below somewhere
Good god, *Scoff* I gotta find this one here. Where is that one?
It looks like if I'm not mistaken that looks like that's the island
So it must be in the nooks and crannies are there I just got to keep looking. Okay, I just gotta keep looking
I'm not gonna stop until I find it like I'm just not like I'm greasy as hell
I need a shower bad, but I'm not gonna stop until I find it have to find this thing
Ah at this point is just a point of pride and I don't even know if it's gonna help me that much
But it's just it's just a point of pride. It's just a point of pride. That's all it is this point of pride
Do you remember that game we used to play you want to play now? I'll go first
What's your best memory from when we were kids? That day
We went outside the dome Apted moved to all well the tree spores were falling. That was your sixth birthday
It was another world of what's your worst the day we moved to all well I everything I knew was all Terra
Still is you're still off in another world? How far would you go to be vice president? It's not your turn
You always make this game not fun to play. You never follow the rules *Light laugh*
Playful banter it's down here somewhere. It said it was super deep
I'm just gonna go super deep and I'm I'm gonna die and I I know but if I can find one before I die
I just they said it was super deep. So I'm just gonna go super deep. What is this quartz?
Ruby okay. There's still some resources around it. Oh god, not a good time still some resources around here. Quartz quartz quartz
Mm
Okay, where am I now no nothing here
There's a path down. That might be it. That might be the super deep that they're talking about. I'm gonna get some oxygen
I'm gonna gun it down there
I'm gonna find me some magnetite if it's the last thing I do
If it's the last thing I do and it's probably gonna be the last thing I do
It's the rarest material in the entire game. Just magnetite. Oh
Yeah. Oh, yeah down here. Oh, yeah
Well, let's assume that this is hiding some magnetite on me
Let's assume that somewhere down here in the deepest of this weird deep place
with weird shroomies is
Magnetite and I am running out of oxygen and I'm gonna die death is coming to claim me and I'm gonna die
That's okay
That's all right
Calorie intake. Is that really my biggest concern when I'm dead. It's not my biggest concern might not be my biggest concern
What did I lose EVERYTHING MY LIFE MY WILL TO LIVE
What if those aren't What if those aren't *Gasp* What if those aren't the base. What's that? Oh
*Mark Sudden Realization*
Are you kidding me?
*Mark Regret exhale*
*Mark Regret inhale*
Ohhhhh
Oh.Okay.
Oh..
*Dumb tone* Oh...
*Mocking tone* OH.
YEAH (Markimoo wanna die after 40 minute of searching)
Yeah..
Yeah that'd be really easy.
Yeah I- I'm not gonna cry. Yup, there she is.
Whoopy doopy! I'll pick ya up and bring ya home!!
I'm gonna cry! *Defeated groan* Oh my god I'm such an idiot.
Ugh! So STUPID.
I'm so dumb. I'm just so dumb
I'm just just so dumb.
I'm dumb, I'm just so dumb
I wish I wasn't dumb have I broken that did I break that now is camera one now broken I-
Oh...Wow, I am all
Kinds of dumb. I am dumb and I think I just broke camera one. I think I somehow managed to break camera one
Yep. You know but it's okay...
I think it's fine and I think that's a good a stopping point as any
To figure out my own
stupidity and
frankly, I
Think that we all learned something today. We all learned that life isn't about
being smart.
Life is about
Adventuring there's camera one camera one's working fine, but let's give camera two a shot. Here we go. Alright
Oh wait. No, I saw that. Where'd it go?
*Stuttering* It was just there.
Ah! Here we go. Yep data box. Let's see what this is all about
Yup, this makes life a lot easier
Oh, no. Whoa. Wow this oh, no, that's that's all that is. I already got that. Okay, that's nothing
Go ahead and get you back in your docking cradle
and blup! And there we go, and I am
Really *Burps* really unsmart.
Oh, yeah. The whole point was to make a computer chip I need
To make a computer chip. Uh, so I need table coral
Right
and
Then we take the computer chip. We put put it in this bad boy and
Bob's your uncle. We've got a hud upgrade
Bada-bing. Where is it?
What? Wh-What the fu- what but oh no, it's it's on me. Oh! Oh!! *Trying to make a sentence*
Look at that
Look at that that is just some that's a slice- Ooo!! That is a slice of something special.
Oh boy!!
*Pitch gets higher* Oh boy!!
*And higher* Oh boy!!
Oh boy, and you know, it's good now!
Now, I've got it all. All right, so thank you everybody so much for watching
I am losing my mind and the depths of the abyss but it's okay
It's alright. So, thank you and have a good night
If you want to see more Subnautica big playlist down in the description take care of yourselves
Take care of each other Tama take care of me. Thanks. And as always, I'll see you in the next video
Bye. Bye
*Loud scream*